I haven't seen so many women like coming  all together you know from every movie  where all of us together we did a  picture like from Tilda - Rachel - Bree  and I just it felt amazing  Captain Marvel herself brie Larson 3 is  our new Captain Marvel he's - oh I made  that joke no great  I love Rito pretty Larson Allison  breathe really Bergen Zula she is  perfect in every way put apart not the  least which is she's a spectacular actor  and really has the range that is going  to be required for our textured and  flawed and deep and real Carol Danvers  and we always talk about our first  casting decision as a studio was Robert  Downey jr. for Iron Man and that set the  bar for us and every time we we bring a  new member into the family we got to try  to get to that bar and she is there  already